LOVED, 'CAUSE SHE'S DEAD.
'CAUSE, I'M KIND
OF THE MAIN OFFICE PRANKSTER.
SECOND, OF COURSE,
TO ROBERTA.
- WHO'S ROBERTA?
- YOUR...MOM.
YOUR MOM, ROBERTA.
- OUR MOTHER'S NAME
WAS KRISTY HOWARD-CLARK.
all: WHAT? [muttering]
- WAS IT?
- KRISTY HOWARD-CLARK.
- I'VE NEVER HEARD
THAT NAME BEFORE.
- SO YOU DIDN'T REALLY KNOW
THIS WOMAN AT ALL EITHER?
- NO, BUT, LIKE,
WHAT IS KNOWING, NOWADAYS?
- OKAY, WHO ARE THEY--
WHO ARE YOU?
- WE'RE LEAVING.
WE JUST WANTED TO SEE
THE GODDAMN HOLLYWOOD SIGN,
AND YOU RUINED OUR LAST DAY
IN AMERICA.
- YOU'RE NOT GONNA THROW OUT
OUR YEARS OF PEN PALLING
BACK AND FORTH OVER
ONE CRAZY DAY?
- I WROTE YOU FOR TWO YEARS.
AFTER MIDDLE SCHOOL, YOU WERE
WRITING WITH MY LITTLE BROTHER.
[both speaking Swedish]
- FOR TEN YEARS I WAS WRITING
TO YOUR LITTLE BROTHER?
OKAY, THAT--THAT CAN'T BE TRUE.
I TOLD HIM I LOVED HIM.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ME--
- IT DOES.
- I HAD YOU FOR TWO YEARS.
AND THE SLEEVE!
- UNBELIEVABLE, I CAN'T BELIEVE
MOM WORKED WITH SUCH IDIOTS.
- BUT SHE MADE US PROMISE
WE'D SHOW YOU THIS VIDEO
IF SHE EVER PREMATURELY
PASSED AWAY.
- HELLO, EVERYONE.
IT'S ME, KRISTY.
THE MAIN OFFICE PRANKSTER.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WONDERFUL
YEARS AT TELAMERICORP.
[burps]
I CHERISH THEM,
AND I CHERISH YOU.
JILLIAN, YOU WERE ALWAYS THERE
TO LISTEN.
- I DON'T THINK
WE EVER SPOKE.
- MONTEZ, THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME BORROW
YOUR WAYNE'S WORLD DVD.
SHA-WING!
AND BILL, I HAD THE BABY.
SHE'S IN PHOENIX.
- PHOENIX!
- AND FINALLY,
ANDERS, BLAKE, AND ALAN--
- ALAN?
- THE OTHER OFFICE PRANKSTERS.
I WANTED TO SHOW YOU A PAINTING
I MADE FOR YOUR CUBICLE.
I'M SO PROUD OF IT, AND I HOPE
THAT IT BRIGHTENS YOUR DAY.
- SHE WAS A PAINTER?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- IT'S RIGHT OVER HERE.
PSYCH!
[all yelling, muttering]
CAN'T UNSEE THIS!
I'M THE MAIN OFFICE PRANKSTER
FOR LIFE, YOU MOTHER[bleep]ERS.
- THIS DOESN'T AFFECT ME.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF PORNO,
THIS DOESN'T AFFECT ME.
- STILL GOT IT.